alors en fait notre partenariat avec la
russie a commencé bien avant 2014
cette année nous fêtons nos trente
années de présence en russie
alors évidemment 2014 a marqué un
tournant quand vous venez de dire ce
qu'il ya eu des sanctions qui ont été
imposées à la russie par la communauté
internationale mais nous vivons avec ces
sanctions
alors évidemment cela nous a demandé de
nous adapter en particulier avec nos
fournisseurs et nos clients russes mais
cela n'a absolument pas changé la nature
de nos relations avec notre partenaire
russe us et saturn et d'une façon plus
générale avec rose tech et ça n'a pas
changé non plus notre relation avec
notre client qui étire coûte
le fabricant d'avions régional soukhoi
superjet est au contraire j'allais dire
que ces difficultés renforcer notre
partenariat puisque plus que jamais on
doit travailler dans la confiance et
dans le respect de la parole donnée
donc finalement nous continuerons à
faire des moteurs pour le sukhoi
superjet le sam146 nous continuons à
travailler avec notre partenaire russe
le sessad fournir au steak avec irkut
certes avec certaines difficultés
puisque nous devons respecter les règles
notamment en termes de financement mais
nous y arrivons et nous y arrivons dans
une parfaite entente
oui dans le domaine aéronautique et dans
le domaine spatial il faut pas l'oublier
non plus effectivement il ya environ une
quinzaine d'entreprises qui sont
présentes certaines à travers un stand
comme power jet comme airbus d'autres à
travers le stand du gifas qui est
groupement des industries françaises
aéronautiques et spatiales et qui montre
encore une fois la volonté de poursuivre
notre partenariat avec la russie et
d'ailleurs je peux noter que d'un parmi
les participants du gifas il ya des
entreprises qui viennent pour la
première fois en russie et qui viennent
effectivement établir des contacts dans
ce contexte économique difficile mais ne
dit on pas que les crises sont aussi une
opportunité
et donc il faut les saisir il faut
continuer et témoigner de notre
attachement à développer cette relation
aéronautique en tout cas avec la russie